Brett McMurphy now of stadium network
college football reporter who sparked a
lot of this with his Facebook reporting
here on the Rich Eisen show I give you
the floor Brett what did you think when
you heard Urban Meyer's say he wish he
had no more thanks for it he he knew
everything the investigative report
shows he knew everything he chose not to
do anything in 2014
Zack rolled up $600 at a strip club on a
recruiting trip Meyer then changed the
coach's manual prohibiting pornography
on any school issued phone so what Zack
do a year later he's taking nude photos
in the White House he's had taking video
of inserting photos of himself having
sex with the secretary and the football
offices and then a few months up to that
Zack Smith is being investigated for
domestic violence in what is Urban Meyer
and Jane Smith do nothing they don't
tell compliance they don't reach out to
Courtney Smith or have anybody from the
university reach out to Courtney Smith
to maybe get her side of this since oh
you know Zack Smith had been arrested in
2009 for domestic violence I opened my
er knew everything that went on members
of the coaching staff knew everything
that went on Urban Meyer deleted text
messages after my August first report
based on a recommendation from a from an
assistant coach so that the media
couldn't get hold of these text messages
I can't take anything that Urban Meyer
says it's truthful because every time he
talks it's proven that he's lying I
think it was disgusting in the fact in
an ad on top of that the investigative
report was incredible I give the
investigative team full credit for that
however releasing that after the press
conference was a joke because now none
of the media members that would want to
follow up questions will ever get these
questions answered because I guarantee
you in three weeks when Evan Meyer is in
front of the media and he gets asked
anything he's going to say look I just
want to focus on the season ahead I
addressed that in the press conference
yeah I know they and and so yesterday
was really the only time where questions
can be asked of him but I do want to ask
you this because I'm sure there's a lot
of Ohio State fans hearing
and your voice you're on the show right
now saying that in in some of the
reporting elsewhere that Courtney Smith
is no angel that there's a lot of of the
he said that needs to be listened to
clearly Ohio State did that how how do
you respond to all those other reporting
and in terms of what you've been able to
determine Brett I would excuse me I
would say that 99.9% of the Ohio State
fans that have a problem with my
reporting if I reported everything word
for word exactly the same way and just
substituted Jim Harbaugh with Urban
Meyer they would love it so it's
basically because it's about their coach
it's about their program I understand
that I guess but again the investigative
report shows all of these incidents that
Zach was was running up the credit
headed credit cards declined on
recruiting trips he was warned about
this by urban urban didn't do anything
urban sent back to a drug rehab facility
in Mason Ohio in 2016 he only stayed for
four of the ten days you know staff
members were aware of the him having sex
with the secretary in the football
offices so if the staff members knew
that this was going on
certainly they told urban because
literally one minute after I reported on
August first
about what Urban Meyer knew concerning
Jack Smith in 2015 an assistant coach
went to him this is in the investigative
report and told him quote there's a bad
article out in quotes and that's when
they started figuring out how to delete
text messages so I'm never going to
change Ohio State fans on this but if
they read the report I think they will
have a much different viewpoint of their
coach maybe they won't because
ultimately Ohio State made a decision
yesterday and that decision was football
is more important than anything else
Brett McMurphy here on the Rich Eisen
show what are the legal issues though
that might have led Ohio state to say
okay it's
it's cheaper to keep him to use that now
you're right yeah well so so technically
he I guess he didn't violate any title
nine policies and any of the school
sexual misconduct policies another thing
urban said that he followed proper
protocol as far as when he was notified
about this well that's a lie he didn't
follow any protocol it's it's known that
the pile police contacted Ohio State's
title nine office they then contacted
Gene Smith he then contacted Exmouth
asking about the 2015 incidents Urban
Meyer didn't follow any protocol because
he didn't do anything because other
people knew about it as far as what
legal issues there were since Ohio State
felt like they could not fire him with
cause and basically mean they don't have
to pay Ohio State or pay Urban Meyer the
40 million I'm sure that was a
consideration because they New Orleans
attorneys would push back on that and
ultimately I think you're right they
figured it would be cheaper to keep him
we give them a three-game suspension and
you know everybody lives on and we worry
about winning in the big ten and getting
to the college football playoff Bret
McMurphy here on the Rich Eisen show and
again based on the report it says
flat-out that Shelley and Urban Meyer
did not believe Courtney Smith even in
the 2009 incident
it just it this whole reading a little
between lines is it be the folks at Ohio
State did not believe Courtney Smith to
be credible based on what I do Zack was
saying or whatever else they knew it was
going on behind the scenes
what does Courtney Smith say about have
you cont have you connected with her at
all since this announcement took place
right I had talked to her she not sure
win so put out a statement on this but
again the reason why they don't find her
credible is because if I'll play along
with it if what she said is accurate
which I have no reason to believe it
wasn't
then that means Urban Meyer's job is in
danger that means every assistant coach
on that staff job is in danger and so
they can do one of two things they can
admit well you know what we find
Courtney credible or we can try to tear
her down and dispute everything she says
and not believe her and then that way
we're still employed in you know we're
making all this money so that's the
easiest route to go Courtney told me
early on when I was talking to her that
in 2013 when the domestic violence
incidents occurred that a couple of
wives the assistant coaches that she had
been in constant contact with basically
said I cannot talk to you anymore I'm
not allowed to talk to you anymore
because their husbands realized that if
this went down then they could all get
swept up into it an urban could be gone
and then they're gone out on the street
so again they have they have a reason to
dispute or try to discredit her because
she is threatening she's not threatening
them but hurt her information ultimately
could could make them lose their jobs
and so that's why they tried to attack
their credibility
it's like Zack Smith goes on ESPN and
says I never abused Courtney Smith well
I've got a text message and I I tweeted
it as soon as he said that where he
admits and apologizes for strangling
Courtney in 2015 in March and in April
so yeah there's a bunch of lies there
because they're all cya they're all
trying to protect their jobs in their
livelihood in the easiest way is to try
to discredit and make Courtney not seem
credible so I guess when this all comes
down to it Brett I mean why do you think
Ohio State did what it did yesterday it
seems like that president Michael Drake
wanted to punish Urban Meyer more
perhaps I don't know if he wanted to
fire him I know he has fired some
high-profile people in the past at Ohio
State that did a lot less than whatever
Meyer did I think ultimately
they decided that like you said I think
financial issues were concerned it's
cheaper to keep him and they could spend
this and just you know say that they've
looked into it and they're ready to move
forward and what they what they said is
football means more than then than
anything else because the fact that they
wouldn't even acknowledge Courtney Smith
in their statements or domestic violence
or anything like that I think that that
shows who they really are
again urban Urban Meyer and gene Smith
were told about the 2015 incidents and
again you don't have to be convicted of
this you just have to have a suspicion
or have knowledge of it to look into it
neither Jean Smith the Urban Meyer told
their compliance Department about that
that a member of their staff was being
investigated for this that's a blatant
cover-up there's no excuse you don't
forget to do that that's a blatant
decision because you don't want this
information to get out and you don't
want it to go any further right thanks
for getting for the phone call we'll
chat down the line I'm sure thank you
you bet Bret McMurphy of stadium Network
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience